ん
[音楽]
me
みなさまこんにちははじめまして
西川右デー
私は現在保育士として日々保育の現場で
働きながら
コミュニケーションインストラクターの
資格を生かして最新の心理学や ai 心理
学第二コミュニケーションスキルや自己
肯定感に関するレッスンを一般の方向けに
行っています
また自分自身の変化や経験などをもとに
インスタグラムや sns を通じて自分
を大切に生きるというテーマを持って日々
発信をしています
突然ですが
みなさんは自分のことを大切にしています
か
最近色々なところで自分を大切にしようと
いうメッセージが聞かれるようになってき
ましたが
今あなたが自分を大切にしていますかとも
し質問をされたとしたら何と答える
でしょうか
いわゆる化していないかと言われるとして
いないかもと思われる方もいらっしゃる
でしょうし
できているという方もいらっしゃれば
自分を大切にするってどういうことと思わ
れている方もいらっしゃるかもしれません
ちなみに過去ば私はというというんできて
いないと思う
そう答えるような人でした
けれど今は大雪していますと応えることが
できるようになりました
今日はもともとは自分を大切にできてい
なかった私が自分を大切にできるように
なったきっかけや変化
モチベーションの使い方や自分を大切に
するヒント
皆様にお届けしたいと思います私の過去
少しお話しさせていただくと
私はもともとネガティブ志向も強い人でし
た
小さい頃からバスケットボールをはずで一
つ年下の妹とずっと一緒にバスケットをし
ていたのですが妹は何でもそつなく
こなせるタイプ
一方の私は何度も練習をしないとできない
タイプでしたので小さい頃から妹と比べる
プセがありました
ただ当時は練習すれば出来るようになる
楽しさがあったり
高校時代は強いチームにいましたので周り
の仲間と生者琢磨しながらも共に同じ目標
に向かって努力をすることで自分の価値の
ようなものを見出してたように思います
しかし部活動を引退し高校から短大へと
進学をすると周りの環境は大きく変化し
ました
今までは自分も周りの友達もすっぴん
ジャージが当たり前の世界だったのに大学
へ行くと周りはメイクをバッチリとして
可愛くていわゆる素敵女子がたくさん
集まっていました
最近では youtube などの sns
を通じて同世代の女性たちの
ライフスタイルが見られるようになり
そういう方々の発信を見てライフスタイル
やファッションなど参考にしているという
方も多くいらっしゃると思いますが
does のお皿に疎かった私はそんな
周りのキラキラした女子たちを着ては
すごく羨ましく思いながら
そうでない自分と比べてしまったんです
そして特に自分の見た目に劣等感を抱く
ようになり
無理ならイエットをしたり私は浮いている
んじゃないかと不安に感じたり
なんで私はこうなんだろうと自分を責め
たりしてコンプレックスがどんどん強く
なっていきました
心理学的に言うと自己肯定感がどんどん
低くなっていってしまったんです
自己肯定感という言葉はご存知の方も多い
と思いますか
少し詳しくお伝えをすると自己肯定感とは
自分は素晴らしい存在なんだと思う気持ち
のことです
性が生きていく上で欠かすこともできない
土台となるもので
人を着て例えるなら
自己肯定感とは大きな木を支えている
根っこの部分です
大きな木が育つためにはしっかりと第一に
根が張っていなければ育ちませんし
と中まで育ったとしても根がしっかり張っ
ていなければ台風が来たら倒れてしまい
ますよね
人も同じで自己肯定感が育っていないと
生きづらさを抱えてしまったり自分らしく
のびのびと生きることが難しいと言われて
います
もともと人は生まれた時は誰もが自分を
愛する力を持って生まれてきますが育って
いる中で様々な要因がきっかけになり
自分は素晴らしい存在なんだという事を
忘れて自己肯定感が低くなっていって
しまうんです
学生時代の私もまさに中うは素晴らしい
存在なんだということを忘れてしまってい
ましたそして私だけではなく残念なことに
この日本は特に自己肯定感が低いと言われ
ているのです
ショッキングなデータを伝えしますが
この資料は先進7カ国での自殺死亡率の
グラフです
日本が一番高く特に15歳から34歳の
若者の自殺死亡率は日本が一番高いそう
です
また2020年にユニセフ位のチェーン系
研究所が発表したレポートカード16
先進国の子供たちの精神的
進退的な健康と学力
社会的つけるについてのランキング
いわゆる子供の幸福度ランキングによると
日本の子どもたちの幸福度は
38カ国中
総合順位て20位となり
分野ごとの内訳で見ると日本は両極端な
結果が混在し進退的な健康は1位であり
ながら
精神的幸福度はなんと30だないという
財界に近い結果にあったことが発表され
ました
このようなデータや研究結果は家庭環境や
学校でのいじめ
メディアからの影響などさまざまですが今
の生活や自分に満足していないという
子どもたちが多く自分を大切両方気持ちが
育まれづらかったり
人と比べてしまったりして自己肯定感が
低くなり生きづらさを抱えている子ども
たちがとても多いと言われているのです
私自身もまさに成長していく中でさまざま
な影響を受けて自己肯定感が低くなって
しまったひとりでしたですから気付いた時
にはもういい意識レベルで自分と周りを
比べる癖が付き
自分を指定したり自分を責めたりして
学生時代はキラ気がした女子たちと自分を
比べ
社会人になると職場の人と自分を比べ
周りの友達が結婚をすれば結構していない
自分に劣等感を感じ
いつも周りの目を気にして周りから好か
れるように嫌われないようにと生きるよう
になってしまいました
そして自分がどうしたいかよりも人から
どう思われるかという他人軸で生きていて
まああれからの評価ばかり気にしていまし
た
そんな学生時代や20代を過ごしていたの
で30歳を迎える頃には私はこのままで
本当にいいんだろうかと強く思うように
なりました
そしてこのままじゃダメだ
そう思い何か自分を変えられる場所はない
かと探したところ
ある一人の王氏と出会いました
その恩師に初めてお会いしたとき私は目
からウロコの衝撃を受けた言葉がありまし
た
それは
誰かに愛されたいならまずは自分を愛する
ことでした
誰よりも一番あなたのことを知っている
自分自身が自分のことを嫌いだったら
そんなあなたを誰が好きになってくれる
でしょうかと
この言葉との出会いだ私の人生の大きな
転機となりました
そこから周りからどう思われるかを気にし
たり嫌われないようにするのではなくまず
は自分を愛すること大切にすることを学び
始めコツコツ実践をしていきました
例えば何かに悩んだときには周りの意見や
常識ではなく自分はどうしたいのかと
考えるようにしたりモヤモヤしたときには
そのモヤモヤを無視しないで
なぜもやもやしているんだろうかと心の声
に耳を傾け
長年積み重ねてきた自分を大切にしない曲
を長い時間をかけて自分を大切にする集歌
上へと変化をさせていきましたそしてこの
ような自分の変化や学んだことを sns
にアップするようになると共感をして
いただけたり自分が成長できるような
チャンスをいただく機会が増え
昨年はミセスオブザイヤーという
コンテストへのチャレンジの切符を
いただき初めてコンテストの世界に
チャレンジをしました
コンテストの練習を始めた当初は
雪花られるなら賞を取りたいということで
目指せグランぴと思って誰かに勝つことを
考えていましたですからどんな人が羊を
するのか気になって他のファイナリストの
方々の sns をチェックするようにて
いました
するとファイナリストの皆さんはやはり
素敵な方たちばかりで
その方の sns の投稿を見て私も
頑張らなきゃとかもっとオシャレに投稿し
なきゃと最初は自分の頑張る
モチベーションにしていましたが
そうやって頑張っているとモチベーション
が上がるどころかどんどん下がっていって
しまったんです
もしかしたら同じような経験がある方も
いらっしゃるのではないでしょうか
そうなんです
私はいつも自分を大切にする考え方や行動
をするように意識をしていたのですが
コンテストという新しい世界にチャレンジ
したことによってまた無意識のうちに他の
人と自分と比べてしまっていたんです
ですからモチベーションは下がり一時期は
練習に身が入らなくなってしまうことも
ありました
そんな時ふと見かけたある記事に書いて
あったアメリカのスーパーモデルミランダ
カーさんの名言に目がとまりました
そこには
柄はひまわりにはなれないわ
ひまわりが腹になることも不可能なの
どんな花もそれぞれ違って美しい
女性も同じと書かれていましたん
この言葉にハッと気づかされ私はなぜ
コンテストに出ようと思ったのか
どんな自分になりたいのかと
もう一度自分と向き合いました
するとそこには1位になりたいとか誰かに
認められたいというような答えは全くなく
て自分をもっと成長させたいというような
答えばかりで誰かと比べ勝とうとしたり
自分をよく見せようとしたり人からの評価
のために自分のモチベーションを使うので
はなく自分が正成長するために自分を
もっと好きになるようにそして自分らしく
いられる方向にモチベーションを使って
いくことが大事なんだなぁと改めて気づく
ことができましたこうしてファイナリスト
の方々との比較を止め
自分自身と戦い自分を大切にしながら
大会当日まで準備を重ねていた結果
地方大会でグランプリを頂き
日本大会のファイナリストとして
幕張メッセの舞台に立つという貴重な経験
をすることができました
このような経験ができたことや
共に頑張った仲間との出会いは本当に人生
の財産となりました
実は今まで心理学の世界では自分の自己
肯定感を高めるためには何か目標を達成し
たりネガティブな言葉は使わずに
ポジティブな言葉を使うようにしたり自分
の自己評価が高ければ高いほど強い
メンタルが作られていき自己肯定栄冠は
高くなると言われていたんです
今回のコンテ添え例えるなら他の間リスト
の方が誰よりも自分が買ったりたとえ
モチベーションが下がっても弱音は一切
吐かずネガティブなことを考えないように
して目標を達成することで自己肯定感が
高まると思われていたんです
しかし最新の研究ではこれらが間違いだと
わかったんです
一人一人が心の底から自己肯定感を高め何
があっても自分で自分を支え自分を愛する
ことができるようになるためには自分に
優しい言葉をかけること
=自分への思いやりが何より大切なのです
海外では既に認知度が高い
セルフコンパッションという考え方で
親友や大切な人に思いやりを持ったり
優しく声を掛けたりするのと同じように
自分自身に対しても思いやりをもって
優しい言葉をかけてあげるという考え方
です
どうしても毎日生活をしているといいこと
ばかりではないですよね
この中でなかなか学校に行けなかったり
友達や家族に会えなかったり
人間関係や様々な焼いもあるかと思います
特にこのリボンは周りの空気を読み相手を
尊重し
はを大切にする文化があるからこそ自分
さえ我慢すれば波風を立てなくて済むから
言いたいことが言えなかったり仲間外れに
されてしまうからと愛てに合わせてしまう
そんな優しい人が本当に多いんですけれど
今世の中も少しずつ変わってきてどんどん
と自分を大切にしようというメッセージが
聞かれるようになってきました
2018年には世界的アイドルグループの
pts がユニセフとともに行った
イベントで
love yourself
まずは十分獅子を愛そうというメッセージ
を世界中に発信し話題となりましたねまず
は自分を愛することまずは自分を大切に
すること
これがこれからの時代を生きていく上で
大切な考え方になるのではないかと思い
ます
誰かと比べるのではなく誰かになろうと
するのでもなくありのままの自分で
ネガティブな感情も丸ごと受け止めて自分
を親友のようにあっ会辛い時には大丈夫私
が味方だよと励ましたり悲しい時にはそれ
は悲しかったねその気持ちわかるよと
寄り添い
どんな時にも自分に優しい言葉を掛け
自分を大切に生きる
そう心の片隅に思いながら
この大変な世の中でも笑顔で過ごせる方が
少しでも増えたら嬉しいなと思いお話をさ
せていただきました
本日の出会いが皆様が幸せな人生を送る
ヒントになれていましたら幸いです
ありがとうございました